How do you stay engaged and up on the
news and still keep your wits about you? Like,
how do you keep your mental health in check while the world is,
seems to be falling apart? Don't watch the news all day, every day.
I don't think our brains are designed to really take that much stimulus
over and over and over. And this is how I feel about Twitter,
even though I am on it more than I should be. If you look at your replies,
I bet you, if you look at your applies, even if they're positive,
it's really overwhelming.
I don't think we're supposed to get that much information,
that much communication, that much feedback from that many people at,
in like such a short period of period of time.
I don't think that was happening in the state of nature where you say something
on the campfire and then all of a sudden, like hundreds of people's steps
with their opinion. Yeah.
Yeah. People are treating you to dunk on you. No, that did not happen.
This is all completely new.
And I agree with you about there being an optimal amount of news and social
media to consume in a given day. Uh, and I've been,
so I I'm on CNN, uh, and CNN has 24 hours of news.
Uh, I grew up in a time when there was approximately 30 minutes of news.
It was just, and here's your nightly news and we'll do it again, like the local,
Virgin and whatnot.
And I'm convinced that there's an optimal amount of news.
That's significantly less than 24 hours. Uh,
because is the fact is if I have hours of
bandwidth of content to fill, then I'll talk about something, you know, and,
and I'll try and make it interesting. Um,
and I'll do enough emotional responses to whatever the heck I'm talking about.
Uh, and that that's, uh, and social media is that compounded, uh,
and you're right that right. So I'm, I'm very much on Twitter. Um,
and it was part of my presidential campaign. So it was very, uh,
it was very, uh, high utility, uh,
and it continues to be high utility because I feel like it's my
responsibility. And I feel, I think you, you,
and Emily's clearly feel similarly where it's my responsibility to try and put
some positive sentiments or ideas, uh,
out there because people kind of turn to me for a sense of
uplift. And I, you know, I'm very touched by that and I,
I want to be that. Uh, and, and,
and so it's, it's like a function of, uh,
who I am now and part of my professional role. Um, but it,
occasionally someone in my Twitter feed will be like, Oh,
I'm trying to get off Twitter. I'm like, go me.
I have friends in Silicon Valley who could not watch Silicon Valley or show on
HBO because they said it just hit too close to home. They were like,
it's too real.
Well, the first time, it's really interesting because our show,
we started filming in 2011, I think maybe 2000,
maybe 2013, I forget. But when we, when I was doing the pilot, you know, it was,
my judge was HBO. I told my friends, I was, if I'm doing this pilot,
they're like, what was it? What's it about it? And I said,
it's called Silicon Valley. And they were like, Oh, is it set in the nineties?
I'm like, no, there's crazy going on in Silicon Valley right now.
It's weird to think back then, we didn't know. I mean, some people did,
but we didn't know who Elon Musk was. We didn't know who Peter teal was. Like,
people had not heard these names. Now these are household names. Um,
in the six years that we ran or the seven years that we ran,
the way that people look at Silicon Valley has changed so quickly.
And for me,
it was a real wake up call because I think it was season two or three,
we would sort of do these trips, right.
We would go to Silicon Valley and we would show the episode and we'd sort of
like tour companies and get to see what they were working on.
And they were very excited to have us because, because, you know, we're,
we're doing a show about, about, uh, about what they do.
I was done at what little thought was
going into the moral and ethical ramifications of the technology that they were
working on. Um, I remember I won't name the company,
but they were showing us this new product.
That's now on the market that many people have. And they were like,
you can do this, you can do this, I can do this.
And so we brought up a privacy concern and it wasn't,
they didn't have,
they were shocked that they were asked this question.
They didn't even have like a fake corporate answer ready to go.
They were stunned and a little upset and disappointed that we would even think
of that. I feel like there's a sense in the tech world. And, and I'm sure,
you know, this much better than I do.
The technology is completely amoral. Uh,
it's a tool you make it and how it's used. Well, it's not up to us.
I don't think that's right. I think first of all,
there's no way that laws can keep up with technology.
And I do think it's the responsibility of people developing this technology to
consider, uh, the negative, the possible negative uses for it. You know?
Um, I can, I mean, the, the deep, fake stuff, all that stuff,
I don't think you can just like keep developing and close your eyes and ears to
the fact that these things can be, can be really misused.
They're being misused every day. Um, in part,
because they serve the almighty marketplace and we know right now the
marketplace just wants to monetize Austin, our attention, um,
whether or not that's good for democracy,
our mental health humanity free will our ability to come together and solve
problems. Our ability to settle on back to the truth. Uh, you know, we're,
we're all now, uh, just subject to this, this, uh,
surveillance capitalism machine, uh,
that sells and resells us to the tune of 200 billion plus a year. Yeah.
That's what you always hear where you're like, if the app is free,
you're the product.
And so right now,
I'm trying to help people wake up to what's going on with our data
and our privacy rights.
There's actually a prompt in California in November prop 24,
that I'm super excited about that it's going to create a dedicated,
uh,
data protection agency in the state of California to look out for California,
uh, data and privacy rights, which right now a lot of companies are frankly,
just totally abusing and just be like, whatever, like there's no enforcement,
of course. So if prop 24 passes in November, then all of a sudden, uh,
the state has to create an enforcement agency and mechanism.
And then you're going to see corporate behavior change because until there's
until deal, actually someone looking after it and then showing up and saying,
Hey, there's a problem here. Uh, so, so believe it or not,
this stuff is the cutting edge right now.
This does literally on the ballot in like a matter of weeks.
Good. I mean, that's the tricky thing, you know, if you see like these hearings,
when wouldn't like Zuckerberg or at any of these folks go,
the questions they're being asked, it's, it's scary.
It's not inspiring stuff.
About the most basic text stuff. Like it just is.
It's really upsetting that, um, I honestly,
I mean this pro prop 24, but he has on prop 24. That's good. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna use to do it to get that word out because I do think that that
is sort of the big existential crisis that we're heading towards right now is,
is, um, is a big tack. I think, I think it's a formidable for,
I feel like for all the great stuff that the internet has done,
I think it's, it's, it's, I mean, you know, it's, it's,
it's fractured the conversations so much to the point where it's not even a
conversation. I remember when I was a computer science major,
I would go to my professor's office.
And he was this guy who was like a philosopher and a computer scientist.
And he was one of the original guys who was involved with the internet and
stuff.
And he had this quote on his desk from a group of early people who were sort of
trying to talk about technology and the benefits it's going to provide humanity.
And it said something like the rise of the internet is the promise
of the return of voice. Um, and I found that so inspiring. I was like,
that's true.
The promise of the internet is I can talk to someone in Bulgaria. You know,
I can like have a real conversation with them.
You really can connect with people who have different experiences from your
different perspectives from you see the world entirely differently,
and you can have a conversation with them.
And reality what's happened is you just find the people who exactly agree with
you.
And then you just talk amongst yourselves and then you yell at the other people
who disagree with you. So, uh, it it's gone in a completely different direction.
I think these original sort of, uh,
tech thinkers had thought had thought it would. Um, and I,
I don't know how, I don't know.
I don't know where we go.
I feel like the internet is like this third print that we made.
That's not swallowing as whole.
Uh,
one of my goals is to get the serpent under control Camille and I may actually
have that job, uh, before too long. If,
if things headed in a particular direction.
I hope they head in a particular direction.
You know, it's funny. I was just using device off the fact that, uh,
I feel like you're one of the most prominent voices in this direction because of
Silicon Valley, which is sort of ironic because obviously it, you know,
it was a television show. And yet I feel like everyone identifies you so closely
with this set of issues. It part, because, you know,
we just watched you on HBO for years on end. I know.
Just saying stuff that they wrote for me,
I really shouldn't be the guy don't look to me for any insight into it. But,
but, you know, we, we, the, the writers and the creators were very, very,
I mean, they knew all these CEOs, right? So.
It's all real, like, you know, the,
the fact that it's like art imitating life or whatnot,
plus the fact that you you're genuinely like a computer science crowd who worked
in the field for years. Uh,
so I don't know if that helped them cast you and they're like, Oh,
this guy's really convincing.
Well, no, because I was really bad at computer science. I never got it,
but I was just,
it's funny to go from sitting behind a row of computers,
being the worst guy to then being,
on-set sitting behind the Royal computers and being the best guy.
Like I was the only one out of the cast that like understood a little bit what
the code was. Uh, so that was.
Weird experience. Thank you for listening in,
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.